hey guys my name is Jess you're watching
GameSpot news it's a brand new week and
a brand new month so happy March it's
May wisi year going speaking of March
May let's talk about the free xbox games
you can grab with your gold subscription
this much on Xbox one you can grab giana
sisters twisted dreams director's cut
for free all month flower Croft and the
Temple of Osiris from May 16 to June
15th and finally The Walking Dead Season
2 is already giving you the fields but
none of your dollars from now until May
15 on Xbox 360 the first half of the
month
is offering up Star Wars The Force
Unleashed 2 while the second half lets
you pick up Lego Star Wars The Complete
Saga let me know if any of these are
sparking your interest in that comment
box and hit that subscribe button so you
never miss our free game PSAs now none
of my friends will play Mario Kart with
me because I swear like a sailor and I'm
a horrible loser but it seems like a low
you guys don't have that problem as the
game is selling pretty damn well the
combined digital and physical sales of
Mario Kart 8 deluxe hit four hundred and
fifty nine thousand units sold on launch
day in the US Nintendo have said this
makes the latest mario kart entry the
fastest selling game in the franchise's
history that record was previously held
by mario kart wii which shifted almost
four hundred and thirty four thousand
units on launch day back in 2008 a press
release notes that the attach rate for
Mario Kart 8 deluxe
is 45% which would mean that us switch
sales are around 1.0 two million units
as you can imagine the Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild remains the switch's
best-selling game to date hitting a
whopping nine hundred and twenty five
thousand sales in the US alone finally
Hideo Kojima has given us another update
on his first post Metal Gear game death
styling at the Tribeca games festival
Kojima confirmed that the team at Kojima
Productions are currently working on
tests using the engine decima decima was
created by Guerrilla Games and was most
recently used to create horizon
very dawn Kadima said the team created a
restaurant setting in New York though he
stressed this is not where the game is
set and are currently working on
figuring out who Norman Reedus is
character will meet their dialogue and
even the menu they're going to look at
he explained we are continuously doing
different tests the game systems the
characters for environments so far it's
going pretty well
something that apparently required no
testing was the inclusion of a naked
Norman Reedus in the death stranding
reveal trailer kijima explained it is
something I very specifically had in
mind I wanted people to see first a
naked Norman shop he added then from the
egg you will be able to see him in
different costumes in different
hairstyles different equipment and
that's as much as I should say today
death stranding sounds like it's still
quite early in development though kijima
has previously stated the game could
release in 2018 that's everything I've
got for you today to let me know what
you cared about down in that comment box
and I will see you again tomorrow with a
bunch more news